orangutangs nurse longer than any other
mammal but figuring out just exactly how
long has been a challenge for scientists
trying to study these treetops dwellers
now a group of researchers has taken a
new approach looking for clues about
Nursing not in the canopies but instead
in orangutan teeth
the researchers turn to decades-old
museum collections for teeth from for
wild orangutan who died before adulthood
just as scientists analyzed the ring
from the tree trunk for clues about a
fallen trees life the researchers
examined teeth for deposits of cerium an
element that comes from mother's milk
researchers found that after a baby
orangutan first year of life barium
deposits varied throughout each year an
orangutan diet consists largely of fruit
and this yearly fluctuation and barium
probably means moms took up nursing
again when that food source was scarce
evidence of nursing continued past eight
years meaning orangutangs are weaned
even later than researchers had thought
scientists hoped that learning more
about orangutan behavior in the wild
will any conservation efforts for these
grenades which populations are predicted
to be cut in half in the next decade
[Music]